this was interesting a new study came
out and found that out of 50 people
listen to this out of 50 people I'm
sorry I'm gonna say this again because I
had as mini-stroke just a second ago why
would you laugh at my Minister as I'm
seeing a new study found that one out of
50 people that makes sense one out of 50
people met the love of their life on an
airplane you believe that one out of 50
that's pretty hot that's pretty high get
this I've been told that that's exactly
how a couple in our audience met tonight
isn't that right it's just true that's
right
I met my Georgie in coach it was a
sold-out Delta flight to Pittsburgh
right baby
I've listened to the Joe Rogan show now
I'm telling him how we met oh hey we met
on an airplane yeah okay sir do me a
favor just take off the headphones all
right hey man I'm a big fan thank you
thank you very much appreciate it I
gotta hit the John
excuse me excuse me excuse me
okay anyway it was then we have a
terrific show tonight director of the
new film blaze Ethan Hawke is on the
program
really funny comedian one of our
favorites Daniel floss is on the show
sorry mr. guest ninja sex party is
homicide
think it's a terrace oh thank you I love
this airline it's not an airline you're
not in an airplane
sorry captain more shows coming up we'll
be right back Jimmy stick around
you